[Music]
go to quranilli.app inshallah the app
tracks versus pages and time spent
reading and the verses to pages function
takes you from reading a few verses a
day to a few pages a day this project is
for the real enthusiasts if there's
enough of us out there this will become
the future of quran apps and support the
project if you can inshaallah may allah
bless all of you jazakallahu
um a lot of people have been contacting
me especially from the subcontinent in
india pakistan and these kinds of
countries
masha'allah you know really appreciate
your support
um
to tell me that you know you should do a
lot more refutations of these kinds of
people like we on the the presenter that
i refuted in the previous uh
in the in the previous video i'll be
honest with you
um
she's a very easy target she was and the
entire organization were very easy and i
think to myself do these people even
think about what they're saying before
they say it because what i'm going to
present to you today
is pathetic it's really pathetic you'll
remember in the previous episode
that one of her main concerns if you
want to put it in that language
with the taliban taking control
or other countries in the in general
actually
was
um this uh women being forced to wear
hijab or head covering and so on in
afghanistan
now we'll talk about that and the
legitimacy of that or lack thereof
in a bit but before we do that i just
want you guys to see
this particular video where she's
talking about
ataturk let's see what she says not too
long ago turkey used to be a modern and
secular state an islamic republic with a
progressive approach thanks to the
policies of mustafa kamal
the father of modern day turkey a
reformer who brought his country at par
with the european world he replaced
arabic with the latin script the islamic
calendar with the western calendar
mosques were under state control faith
was a private matter christians and jews
could freely worship their gods in
turkey turkish men were forbidden from
wearing a headgear turkish women
forbidden from wearing head scarves but
the turkey of today is very different
now turkey is ruled by a leader who
wants to take his country back to its
ottoman ambitions
i was listening to this thinking is this
woman for real
is this woman for real she mentioned a
few things
the ataturk dumb in his premiership
and one of those things was that he
banned hijab
and i want to say something
the silence
is deafening
the acquiescence
is clear
and in fact the tone was encouraging
from your perspective
why when it comes to
a nationalist secularist
if your paradigm
is a liberal one
do you not comment in a negative manner
do not condemn
banning or restrictions
to clothe
to clothing especially women women's
clothing but when it comes to the
islamic discourse you do exactly that
this already reveals to me
that you are a hypocrite
you are an absolute hypocrite it's not a
matter
of moral consistency here
it is a matter of
strategic consistency
in fact you have just fell
face-first
into an intellectual ditch you're
embarrassing yourself
this is absolutely shocking
i can't believe it almost to be honest
i'm lost for words but i must say
the problem is the notion in the first
place
that a woman
in the west even
has any
or every right to wear whatever she
wants
this is a false notion
and it can be proven or disproven i
should say with the easiest
of introspection
if i say for example
if a woman wears a bikini in the bank
okay look we've been living i've been
living here all my life i'm a westerner
what's your name i don't know prakash
whatever your name is sorry to say i
don't know your name yeah but i'm a
westerner
i've been educated in the west and i've
been an educator in the west i don't
want you to worship me now please don't
worship me
okay because i know you worship
the creation
not the creator was a lot of your people
they worship the creation aside from the
creator i don't want to go to bombay and
see like a statue of the great hijab
there
muhammad the learned hijab there i don't
want to see this
so please don't worship
but i've been uneducated i've been
educated there in the west
and i've been an educator here in the
west for some time and i can tell you
from my experience and i think people
will share this experience here in the
west
and that in fact
women can't wear what they want
i mean a woman cannot wear a bikini in
the bank now she might be able to get
away with it i mean i don't think
anyone's stopping maybe the police will
come i don't know
but i can tell you for a fact that a
woman cannot wear a bikini
in a school
now if she works in a secondary school
uh she i mean i've been in schools where
women have been told not to have a lot
cleavage hanging out if she's teaching
you a 10-11 why because it will distract
the students this is very fair or you
could say a common
policy
you cannot imagine it's inconceivable
that women will wear bikinis to work in
a school or in a corporate even
corporate environments
and in fact they'll probably be sent
home
i guarantee you they'll be sent home
women that go
to corporate environments or secondary
schools or university places or
hospitals or any of those places which
are
we're talking about tens of millions of
women here just in the uk a population
of i don't know 70 something million
they will be sent home if they wear
those clothes they have uniform they
have to wear
and it will be seen as inappropriate
and public exposure
but why can the same woman
go to a beach and wear the bikini and
there's no issue i mean who gets to set
these guidelines have you ever thought
about it have you ever thought about who
gets to set these societal conventions
why is it acceptable in the beach but
and
it's not and on the roadsides or in a
park but it's not acceptable in a bank
or a hospital or in a school
you could give me a reason you tell me
well because one will cause a
distraction
okay
well maybe if if wearing such clothing
causes a distraction the question is at
what point does it stop causing a
distraction
and where does the line where is the
line drawn what a woman where is the
miniskirt in a corporate environment
doesn't that cause some kind of
distraction are the hormones hormone
levels of men
that much drastically different
or that the behavior of such men will be
completely different
in corporate environments to hospitals
to to this but who gets to who gets to
sorry to say
set those cultural conventions
i tell you gets to do it for the most
part
white men
and once again
well when i'm saying that maybe you've
already jumped into prostration but
before you do get back up
get back up
listen to what i'm saying
white men maybe white women as well yeah
the feminist movement has had a huge
i would say influence as well
but why should we follow those
regulations
they are legally enforceable
organizationally enforceable
structurally enforceable institutionally
enforceable so many times
and so you can't say women can wear what
they want in the west they can't that's
that's that is a misnomer
that is a that is fallacious reasoning
that is wrong legalistically false
john stuart mill himself
he had limits with the father of social
liberalism he said people having sex in
the roadside should be banned
fortunately mexico didn't take his
advice but that's another story for
another day
the point i'm making to you is what is
that much different
the only difference is in the type of
clothing
well you might say well it's actually
more coverage you know the islamic
garment
but when girls go to girls schools or
even mixed schools
or even boys go to such schools they are
told what to wear
ex by color
that you know even the color they have
to if you don't have the tyre you go
back home what do you mean what do you
mean you go back home if you don't have
a tie
isn't that restricting what you wear you
can't wear what you want this is a
misnomer what country do you think this
is do you think
where do you think we are living in the
nudest place the west is a new this
place this is a huge misconception
so that's the first thing i want to say
the second thing is clear your hypocrisy
is very clear
why do you allow
girls to be segregated in girl schools
in olympic events for them to have
designated uh uniform all of these
things legally enforceable in in
organizations and institutes but when
the taliban do it with a different or
these guys do or whoever doesn't you're
thinking this is so much it's so weird
it's not that it's not to be honest with
you it's not that weird it's very
similar to what you guys already impose
but it's just in a different format
it's all it is it's in a different
format
now the question is now a sharia
question
since you you're the expert in sharia of
course yeah
you didn't know what the massage of
sharia were but you're the expert which
means the the sources of sharia the
point is
what happens in a sharia state is there
any had punitive law that stipulates the
quran
for a woman who doesn't wear hijab
there's no such heart actually mentioned
that doesn't mean to say they can wear
what they want
because the quran states
that's not for a muslim man or a muslim
woman if allah and the messenger have
chosen something for them to have any
choice in the matter because if you
really are a muslim muslim someone who
is submitting to allah you believe that
this religion is from god then this is
this this is the godly uniform if you
like
if you don't want to be a muslim if
you're not muslim
there's no compulsion religion but this
verse is for non-muslims as for muslims
is these are our guidelines why why are
our guidelines so foreign and your
guidelines so
the ones that we should all follow you
haven't even given us reasons
do you not see the patheticness of your
you're pathetic
you haven't even argued for your case
so i say
this is a really weak approach the
second thing is i want to
also point
to the fact that when it comes to
religious freedoms
your colleague
look what she says about
encouraging of macron and his policies
which are anti-muslim
and once again one of the policies is to
restrict women's dress code but let's
see what your your colleague says about
this
we start off with the latest coming in
from france where the lawmakers have now
approved president emmanuel macron's new
law that proposes to fight radical
islamism
the law aims to strengthen oversight of
mosques schools and sports clubs to
safeguard france from radical islamists
so once again here look at this
encouraging tone when it comes to whom
when it comes to the secular republican
macron
it's not that you're liberal by the way
you're not liberal
you might call yourself liberal
but you're disguising fascism with
liberalism quite similar to hitler quite
similar to your president actually modi
the bastard
yes the bastard
the one who's allowing all of these
things to happen with minorities in his
uh in his country
this individual here
you are
exposed already as an individual
and the proof is in the pudding because
if had you not been a fascistic person
at least an inclination
then you would have some kind of liberal
consistency which you don't and i have
nothing else to say to you you're
finished good night
you